Tonie people want to know what's the
single best piece of advice you've ever
been given how's that so much but I
think one of the most important ones was
early in my life one of my mentors men
named Jim Rohn said Tony all you have to
focus on your life is find a way to add
more value than anybody else does and
you'll never have to worry about
anything be the person that does more
for others and life will just be any one
thing you want out of it really is what
it is so and he also said the way to do
that is every day work harder on
yourself anything else because if you
become more intelligent more valuable
more skilled you can add more value to
other people thank you guys so much for
watching this is another test series
that I'm running with we're looking at
famous entrepreneurs and figuring out
what their single best piece of advice
if they ever received was let me know
what you think about this video let me
know what you think about the series if
we should continue or not leaving the
comments below I'll join the discussion
thank you so much for watching you need
to believe and I'll see you soon